[Music]
today
[Applause]
[Music]
there are a hundred and seventy-eight
loss a differentiate on the basis of sex
women can work overtime we have to get
credit cards in our husbands name not
allowing
you think you can change the country you
should look to her generation they're
taking to the streets protests are
important but changing the culture it
means nothing if the law doesn't change
who did you say your name was Ruth Bader
Ginsburg I want to be a lawyer I want to
represent clients in pursuit of justice
so they're gonna give you a corner
office I wasn't what they were looking
for one said women are too emotional to
be lawyers another told me a woman
graduating top of her class must be a
real ballbuster I worked hard I did
everything I was supposed to and I
excelled Martin Ginsburg will be signing
all of our checks someday Chris Marker
with you married a star if the law
differentiates on the basis of sex then
how will women and men ever become equal
I don't read Tax Court cases read this
room
the law assumes a caregiver has to be a
woman this is sex-based discrimination
against a man poor guy we need to take
this case is not a case this is a
declaration of war he could topple the
whole damn system of discrimination they
think gender equality is a civil right
what's at stake is the American family
let's put this idea to bed once and for
all you will lose and when you do you
will set the woman's moving back ten
years you don't get to tell me when to
quit I know this case disrupted our
lives kusa for if not for me
you've been ready for this your whole
life so going there and let the judges
see there was Ginsburg I know we're not
asking you to change the country
I've already happened without any
court's permission
the word woman does not appear even once
in the US Constitution nor does the word
freedom your honor
[Music]
you
you